In this video we will review how to monitor scan progress.
The timeline shows you the progress of a scan so that you can see what stage you set and
how much time remains.
In order to monitor the scan progress, select Scans, select the scan in question and ensure
you have selected the timeline tab.
Notice that the following information is shown, the current scan status.
Start time, time remaining and duration.
Additionally, we can review the timeline itself, the current phase and what vulnerabilities
have been located.
Please note the time remaining for your scan depends on several factors including your
chosen scan configuration.
You can also review the timeline for completed scans which can help you troubleshoot any errors
that may have occurred.
When reviewing scan errors, the timeline will show them where applicable.
The error messages will include information about the cause of the issue and possible remediations.
We will see any errors indicated on the progress bar by red cross X.
the error messages.
Thank you.
The error messages.